I know named middle-aged b-list actor
duking it out with stuck men in costumes
likes hunting choreography at the extras
in those robot suits really knew it I'd
take a punch Oh literally echo Jonathan
not to hold back give it all to him kick
him in the nuts I'm old and I know what
you're thinking but don't worry sweet
handled it responsibly we made them all
sign waivers not to super injury
if I Len squarely on that grain silo I
should survive this fall unscathed I
shouldn't say this now but you could
actually see the strings if you squinted
hard enough
I bet you didn't notice but this was
actually heading nowhere near that grain
silo a little editing room magic and no
one hardly noticed it appears some of my
equipment was lost when my ship was shot
down but what luck this high-tech
scanner reports that my ray gun is
nearby oh the dinosaurs just don't see
quality stop motion like this someone
actually SAT there and move them frame
by frame today if you done with
computers but where's the artistry in
that oh oh the fearless sea monster
always patrolling the shore eagerly
awaiting for his next video now if the
trees here look a little plastic well
it's because they are I took them from
the set of my last film vampire island
too I designed this creature to reflect
the human condition always hungry never
satisfied the bottomless pit we got our
fair share of nasty letters from
scientists complaining about our
portrayal of the dinosaurs was news to
me apparently these data sources weren't
leaders must have preferred shellfish or
something Wow how do they know that's
what I said
haha
as usual the local population is
defenseless that's where our heroes
steps in and saves the day look we
pushed Jonathan through a lot shooting
this film he wasn't the best actor
especially when reacting to getting hit
he's watching called a glazier so I
throw the stock manda thrilling to go to
town on